If I gave one piece of advice
to the world about how to avoid
diseases,
I would say have clear lines of
definition and demarcation and that
makes it sound like I'm recommending
exercise as number one because I want
the absence of fat under the skin.
I think that is the single most powerful
generator of most diseases.
It affects cholesterol,
it affects triglycerides,
that affects diabetes,
therefore dialysis,
therefore blindness,
therefore amputation.
It affects cancers and so on.
So the best way to do that is of course
to put diet and exercise together as far
as,
um,
uh,
immunizations.
Frankly,
that's a question,
uh,
in our culture that is mostly immunize
those people who choose not to get
immunized or sort of living off the
benefits of those who did because the
disease incidence is low,
but there have been several studies to
show that whooping cough epidemics have
begun to occur in those populations who
have not been immunized or adequately
immunized or recently enough been
immunized and whooping cough is nothing
to fool around with.
Frankly,
my children are grown and I don't know
what I would do if the question were
asked me now,
uh,
do you want your kids immunized for all
of the things they're doing?
I will say this,
I would spread it out a little bit.
I don't think you need to jump in and
the first week or month and start the
immunization process as for seat belts
and,
uh,
you know,
avoiding too much sun and hence
melanoma.
You shouldn't be in the sun.
Vitamin D levels are very low in our
culture.
You should be in the sun before 11:00 or
after 1:30.
Uh,
and you need a great deal.
You need a high vitamin D low.
You should not avoid the sun.
You should be in the sun.
What's happened?
If you've already developed a skin
cancer of some variety,
then you really need to think about
taking vitamin D as a supplementation in
our western culture.
I think virtually everybody should
probably be on vitamin D.
I've never seen one person who had a 25
hydroxy vitamin D,
three level of 80,
which is considered more or less the
best level.
Everybody in my practice of thousands of
patients is below that number,
so I think just across the board,
people need vitamin D.
I've seen a few people in the seventies,
uh,
but uh,
not missing.
Everybody has a genetic predisposition
to develop multiple disorders,
but those disorders occur if only if the
person does what's necessary to express
that weakness.
So those people who are exercising
adequate,
virtually everyone who follows an
organic,
unprocessed whole foods diet that the 87
point five percent level and who
exercises a an hour a day is going to
have the kind of physique that I've just
recommended.
And of course that's a lot of time and
people say,
who has the time,
pay me now or pay me later,
do what you're supposed to.
And then you'll find out that you'll
avoid diseases.
Dr. Visit a high copays,
high health insurance being rated by
your insurance,
having surgery and so on and so on.
So if you put the time in,
now it's sort of like an education.
You put the time and now you get the
benefit down the road,
you should get a rectal examination for
cancer.
Of the prostate,
I think thermography is a better way for
women to go than mammograms.
It's a heat registering technique that
gives no radiation.
There is a time and a place for a
mammogram.
There's a time and a place for an MRI
and of course now the big hot news about
cat scans and so on is that they are
cancer generating at about one in 500.
So I'm a.
people over the age of 50 should get a
colonoscopy and people should be doing
stool blood for a Globan Glo bin or
what's called a cult blood,
uh,
to detect cancers of the bow.
If you have stomach distress and
intolerance,
you might need to be checked for a bug
in your stomach called h dot pylori or
wheat allergy called CELIAC disease.
So these are some of the kinds of
things,
but everybody should get their
cholesterol checked.
Everybody should get their diabetes
checked.
There are 25 hydro a diabetes test
called an a,
one c,
they should get cholesterol,
which should be less than 1:50.
Triglycerides,
which should be less than 100.
A one C,
which should be less than five point
five,
25 Hydroxy d three,
which should be right around 80.
And those are some of the biochemical
tests that might be of interest for
people.
Um,
but,
uh,
we've mentioned a colonoscopy,
mammogram,
rectal examination,
pap and pelvic for women.
Uh,
I do think that as much as I have
hesitancy about the injection of foreign
proteins called immunizations,
if I had a daughter,
I probably would want her immunized for
HPV.
Uh,
but again,
I wouldn't rush into it,
but once you became sexually active,
I would certainly want to have a
discussion until she made a final
decision whether or not it should be my
decision at this point.
So she doesn't have a voice in,
uh,
that,
is a different discussion.
Disease reversal is not impossible.
You can reduce the weight of diabetics
and for all apparent reasons,
uh,
hi.
Uh,
their diabetes goes away.
You can do the same for high blood
pressure.
You can,
for lack of a better word,
put it in quotes.
Cure.
There are doctors who argue against that
saying that you cannot cure.
I'm a hypertension.
You cannot cure diabetes,
you cannot cure high cholesterol.
Well,
it's very academic,
whether you want to argue about can you
cure it or not,
I can make all the signs of it go away
or reduce a person to Claude,
clear lines of definition and
demarcation.
Most diabetes will go away.
The vast majority of hypertension will
go away.
Then of course,
you have to address salt.
A salt intake has to be comparatively
low.
Um,
and uh,
um,
you have to address exercise.
So I believe that for the most part,
diabetes can be reversed.
Almost 90 percent of high cholesterol
can be reversed.
Virtually 95 percent of high
triglycerides can be reversed.
Um,
cholesterol,
blood pressure,
diabetes,
cigarette smoking.
Uh,
it's been shown time and time again.
If you stopped smoking,
the cells in your lungs begin to change
back to what they should have been and
so on.
Plus,
you'll reduce,
when you do all these things,
you reduce back pain,
you reduce depression,
uh,
you reduce a predisposition to accident.
Overweight people have more accidents.